Es spricht wirklich immer mehr dafür, dass
uns wirklich eine Aliensonde besucht hat.
Das Objekt Oumuamua war schon ziemlich seltsam,
aber weitere Untersuchungen legen tatsächlich
sehr Nahe, des es sich nicht um ein natürliches,
sondern ein künstliches Objekt gehandelt
haben muss, sprich eine Aliensonde, ein von
Außerirdischen ausgesendete Sonde.
Es ist nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich, dass dieses
Datum in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen.
Wie das Forschungsteam auf die Idee kam?
Die Hintergründe jetzt bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich megaspannenden Science
Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, denn nur dann verpasst
ihr kein Video.
herzlich willkommen.
So haben sich Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
Oumuamua bisher vorgestellt.
Ein ganz langer Stein.
Allein das war schon sehr seltsam.
Und es scheint auch nicht so zu sein.
Oumuamua oder 1I das erste interstellare Objekt
ist wahrscheinlich eine Aliensonde.
Wir hatten ja mit als erste drüber berichtet.
Die Medien sind extrem vorsichtig und nur
wenige melden diese Nachricht.
Das ist auch verständlich, denn es klingt
schon extrem verrückt.
Eine Aliensonde soll uns besucht haben.
Aber sogar die renommierte Zeitschrift Spektrum
hat inzwischen darüber online berichtet und
das will schon etwas heißen.
Es ist eben auch nicht irgendein Forschungsteam,
sondern mit dabei ist Abraham Loeb, Professor
für Astrophysik an der Harvard University,
Direktor des Institutes for Theory & Computation
(ITC) im Harvard-Smithsonian Center for Astrophysics
und Vorsitzender des Fachbereiches Astronomie
der Harvard University und Doktor Shmuel Bialy.
Er ist Stipendiat am Institutes for Theory
& Computation (ITC).
Ein Team vom Fach und dazu mit einem absolut
renommierten Astrophysiker an der Spitze und
er ist zudem Vorsitzender des Beratungsausschusses
des Breakthrough Starshotprojektes.
Initiert von Stephen Hawking und Juri Millner,
einem russischen Milliardär ist das ein Projekt
bei dem dutzende Miniraumschiffe an Minisonnenesegeln
Richtung Alpha Centauri geschickt werden.
Millner hat es mit 100 Millionenen Dollar
finanziert.
Ein Laser soll seinen Impuls auf ein nur wenig
Gramm schweres Sonnensegel geben.
Er schiesst von der Erde aus und beschleunigt
die Minisonden auf extrem hohe Geschwindigkeiten,
Trotz dieser hohen Beschleunigungen wird ihre
Reise zu unserem Nachbarsonnensystem wohl
über 20 Jahre dauern.
Die Sonden sind dabei im Gegensatz dazu extrem
klein.
Testsonden wurden bereits in den Erdorbit
gestartet und kreisen bereits um die Erde.
Es sind die kleinsten je in die Erdumlaufbahn
geschickten Satelliten.
Sie messen und 3,5 mal 3,5 Zentimeter.
Mini, mini, mini also.
1000 Mal kleiner als die bisher kleinsten
Satelliten, die Cubesats, die so etwa ein
Kilogramm wiegen.
Die Sprites, so werden diese Mikroraumsonden
genannt wiegen dagegen nur 4 Gramm.
Denkbar wäre dabei auch, dass die Minisonden
jeweils unterschiedliche Aufgaben haben.
Einige könnten Fotos machen, andere Daten
aus der Atmosphäre sammeln undsoweiter.
Das größte Teil an diesen Sonden ist jeweils
das Sonnensegel.
Es muss extrem groß sein, um möglichst viel
Schub zu entwickeln.
Bei dem Projekt würden ganz viele solcher
Sonden Richtung Alpha Centauri fliegen, um
dann im kurzen Vorbeiflug Daten zu sammeln.
Allerdings hätten sie nur sehr kurz Zeit.
Denn der Vorbeiflug wäre mit der hohen Geschwindigkeit
sehr schnell wieder vorbei.
Genau wie bei der mutmaßlichen Aliensonde.
Sie flog mit hoher Geschwindigkeit an der
Erde vorbei und entdeckt haben wir sie erst,
als sie sich schon wieder entfernte.
Die Wissenschaftler halten es für wahrscheinlich,
dass genau so ein Minisatellit mit seinem
riesigen Sonnensegel an uns vorbeigeflogen
ist.
Denn das Objekt ist so beschaffen gewesen,
wie es für die Sonden geplant ist.
Ein riesiges Sonnensegel, das superdünn ist.
Die Studie kommt zu einer Dicke von 0,3 bis
0,9 Millimeter.
Und ein natürliches Material, das diese Eigenschaften
hat ist nicht bekannt und auch einfach unvorstellbar.
Wie soll die Natur so etwas “bauen”.
Es kommt nur eine intelligente Spezies in
Frage, die quasi das Breakthrough Starshot
Projekt schon vor einiger Zeit in die Tat
umgesetzt hat.
Gebaut vor etwa 100 Jahren und in 25 Jahren
bekommen sie vielleicht die Daten.
Und dabei können es auch mehrere Sonden gewesen
sein und wir haben nur eine entdeckt oder
aber nur eine hat uns erreicht.
Die Flugzeit habe ich jetzt mal aus dem Breakthrough
Starshot errechnet.
Hierbei sollen die Sonden etwas 20 Prozent
der Lichtgeschwindigkeit erreichen und das
4 Lichtjahre entfernte Doppelsternsystem Alpha
Centauri im Sternbild des Zentauren am Südhimmel
in rund 20 Jahren erreichen.
Oumuamua kam aus dem 25 Lichtjahre entfernten
System Wega.
Wahrscheinlich nicht genau aus diesem System,
aber aus dieser Richtung, weil bei Wega bisher
aber nur eine Staubscheibe gefunden wurde
und ein Exoplanet nur vermutet wurde und das
System zudem auch noch sehr jung ist kommt
Oumuamua wahrscheinlich eher aus der Nähe
und nicht driekt von Wega.
Aber wer weiß.
Auf jeden Fall würde dann die Reise zur Erde
etwa 100 Jahre dauern und das Rücksenden
der Daten 25 Jahre.
Also der Besuch von Aliens zumindest aufgrund
der Untersuchungsergebnisse dieser Sonde steht
also noch in den Sternen, im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes.
Jetzt müssen wir diese Region auf jeden Fall
genauer untersuchen.
Wer weiß, was dort zu finden ist.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert am besten auch den englischen
Kanal (hier einfach draufklicken) von Clixoom.
Da gibt es auch die ein oder andere Videopremiere.
Glocke nicht vergessen.
Und hier geht es weiter mit “Mysterious
Object detected: Neither a star nor a planet?”
See you soon, stay tuned!